[Musica]
non ce la farete mai questo è stato
detto all'età di 14 anni quando dicevo
ai miei conoscenti che volevo fare
business online e come biasimarli
effettivamente quanti di voi mi
avrebbero dato del pazzo alzate le mani
per quelli che non hanno alzato non ci
credo a pensarci forse dovevo essere un
po pazzo a pensare una cosa del genere
ma comunque sono riuscito a raggiungere
il mio obiettivo è aprire mi e commerce
e mio business online e sono cresciuto
molto in questo percorso ma nonostante
tutto anche adesso ma dove non un
ragazzo della mia età e cerca di
spiegargli qual è il suo lavoro mi
guardano e pensano cosa fa esattamente
questo ragazzo sì questa è la reazione
che suscito normalmente perché come
tutti sapete la percezione che si ha dei
giovani è che siano pigri e svogliati
poi arriva la domanda successiva
naturalmente per molti la più importante
ma quanto guadagni
quasi con tono provocatorio come se
volessero farti capire quanto in realtà
tu sia un fallito
ma quando rivedo la risposta a
quest'ultima domanda accorgendo si di
aver sbagliato o ci rimangono male è kg
nella discussione oppure ti fanno i
complimenti perché non lo credevano
possibile perché viviamo in un mondo
così incentrato sull'apparenza che a
nessuno importa più della della sostanza
in un mondo che vive nella mentalità del
pregiudizio
non importa quanto bravo intelligente di
successo tu sia le persone oggi nella
vita reale e sui social vivono con un
filtro quello di instagram
una realtà quindi di farti ammirare per
forza se no non sei nessuno la verità è
che al giorno d'oggi l'abito fa il
monaco
ed è proprio su questo che ho costruito
mio business online compro prima di
tutti delle scarpe limitate di cui c'è
una grande richiesta e poi le rivendo al
momento giusto ad un prezzo più alto
rispetto a quello a cui lo acquistate
mi ricordo molto bene la prima volta che
sono entrato in contatto con questa
tipologia di scarpe
era uno dei primi giorni delle scuole
superiori durante la ricreazione stavo
parlando con un mio amico
a un certo punto lo vedo bloccarsi di
colpo durante un discorso è abbastanza
perplesso lo guardo e chiedo ti senti
bene
lui annuisce
io ancora più confuso cerco di capire
cosa stesse guardando ne accorgo che
stava guardando un ragazzo con un paio
di jordan 1 le prime scarpe create per
michael jordan le prime che abbia mai
indossato quelle con cui la sua storia
ha avuto inizio
mi è rimasto impresso come un semplice
capo di abbigliamento potesse creare un
così forte magnetismo quelle scarpe
quelle scarpe per cui decine a volte
centinaia di ragazzi si mettono in fila
ore a volte giorni prima della data di
uscita per essere sicuri di poterle
comprare di poterle toccare di poterle
ammirare ma soprattutto di farsi
ammirare sì perché una scarpa non è un
semplice oggetto è un simbolo che fa
capire agli altri chi sei o come vuoi
che ti vedano raccontano una storia
e proprio per questo motivo il mercato
di queste scarpe si sta velocemente
espandendo
pensate che l'anno scorso secondo la
ricerca statistica della manchester
metropolitan university il mercato di
queste scarpe ha subito un incremento
del 200 per cento raggiungendo la quota
di 6 miliardi di dollari e secondo le
previsioni quest'anno per registrare un
altro aumento del 65 per cento
raggiungendo l'incredibile quota di 10
miliardi di dollari 10.000 milioni
sempre solo nel continente americano
ma la vera domanda che vi sta seguendo
sia ma come le è venuto in mente ancora
tredici anni di aprile un business
online ma soprattutto come ci è riuscito
la risposta è complessa tutto ha avuto
inizio in estate quando ho passato un
paio di settimane a chiedermi come
potevo conciliare la scuola con la
creazione del mio primo business online
a quel tempo era un ragazzino
appassionato di computer che ha deciso
di buttarsi a ricerca di opportunità
nell'ambito online ed è riuscito
fortunatamente a trasformare la sua
passione per le scarpe in un lavoro
l'online il nuovo ambito lavorativo
molto discusso e spesso visto come male
del mondo moderno
noi non credo sia così
come tutti i cambiamenti è ovvio
impaurisce e fa arrabbiare in molti ma
anche un nuovo mondo di opportunità
il mondo dei giovani che può permettere
ad altri con di spingersi dove anche
usando una decina di anni fa non sarebbe
stato possibile arrivare dove è
possibile attingere a informazioni
conoscenze e opportunità lavorative e
tutto con un semplice click
dovunque vi troviate nel mondo
ma nonostante tutto non è stato solo
l'online a permettermi di iniziare un
business online da così giovane
perché la vera differenza l'ha fatta
essere stato un quattordicenne così
determinato da non avere paura di
provare a buttarsi per questo il punto
fondamentale della mia storia la cosa
che ha fatto veramente la differenza è
stato il mio mindset in mine set la
mentalità il nostro modo di pensare
ora se vi dicessi che mi ha mai 7 a 14
anni me lo sono costruito da solo sarei
un illuso perché dei nostri caratteri e
le nostre esperienze di vita cambiano
radicalmente il nostro modo di pensare
immaginate molto semplicemente che dieci
anni fa i vostri caratteri esperienze di
vita fossero le stesse di oggi
ricominciando da quel punto avreste
preso scelte diverse ma soprattutto oggi
sareste persone diverse
tutto sarebbe cambiato radicalmente
nella vostra vita perché il nostro main
set può evolversi o regredire a causa
nostra
successiva quindi sorge spontanea perché
per me è mai 7 così importante ma
soprattutto qual è il mio attuale mine
set dopo aver fatto un salto nel vuoto
ed essere fortunatamente ancora in piedi
o tre punti fondamentali che segue
il primo è che cominciò pensando al
finale
durante il mio percorso scolastico
lavorativo
mi veniva spontaneo chiedere il perché
lo faccio perché sto spendendo così
tanto tempo energie su queste cose ogni
volta la mia risposta era sempre la
stessa perché avevo ben chiaro in testa
dove voleva arrivare è da lì che sono
partito dal finale perché è solo in
questo modo che è possibile creare un
percorso per raggiungere i propri
obiettivi
passo dopo passo
avendo pur sempre all'uscita di
correggere la rotta per raggiungere la
propria meta
il secondo punto è fondamentale è che il
lavoro e la mia passione
fin da piccolo mi è sempre piaciuta la
figura dell'imprenditore il fatto di
essere capo di me stesso di accettare
consapevolmente che le mie decisioni
possono portare o al successo o il
fallimento e quattro anni dopo l'inizio
di questo percorso ho capito che essere
un imprenditore non è stata
semplicemente una mia scelta ma è sempre
stato dentro di me
sperimentate trovate quel lavoro che vi
prende così tanto da dimenticare tutto
il resto perché si riesce ad amare il
processo e le piccole cose che non
comporta quella sarà la vera vittoria
per voi la felicità
il terzo e ultimo punto
è che io non temo il fallimento
doveva hanno capito
se avesse
persone che mi avevano detto che non ce
l'avrei mai fatta oggi non mi troverei
qui viviamo in una realtà quella
italiana il cui il fallimento ha
ridicolizzato è la fine se fallisci ti
dicono cambia cosa fai perché ci provi
ancora hai sbagliato non ascoltarmi io
non la vedo così io credo ci sia molto
di più di questo in un fallimento
io vedo un opportunità
abbiate la forza di rialzarmi ma non
prima di aver capito come ci siete
finiti al tappeto fallite rialzatevi
fallite di nuovo fallite meglio
questo è mai set che mi rende quello che
sono oggi uno studente un imprenditore
un diciottenne con tutta la vita davanti
ora però chiude gli occhi voglio che
pensate al vostro sogno voglio che lo
visualizzate cristallino nella vostra
mente
ora gli occhi non ce l'ha hetemaj ed è
proprio da qui che la vostra storia
dovrebbe iniziare dimostratemi il
contrario
[Applauso]